see it does it just doesn't seem like I
hello everybody my name is markip and
welcome back to Five Nights at Freddy's
help wanted nothing new here nothing
crazy going on there's a photo booth
there and I'm not 100% sure what that's
for but we're going to keep going with
this I think we have to do a makeover
we've got more viruses popping up but
we've unlocked a whole bunch so I
imagine that it's makeover time places
please prepare staff Bots for showtime
in The Green Room okay I don't know why
the staff Bots are doing Showtime help
the staff Bots get ready for their
performance put the right makeup on how
do I know how do I how do I know what
the right makeup is I mean I imagine
they're going to tell me but it the new
wardrobe assistant oh my God the staff
prepare for Showtime they will need hats
glasses and makeup your task is simple
match the head shot confirm Readiness
but your next subject enters attention
to detail is key be great about it do
not make them miss their cues super
numerary Talent can hold a grunch it is
best practice to stay on their good
side oh my God super
numerary as in oh my God oh my
God hi oh I love this oh yeah this is
really good um okay oh man I'm running
out of time uh this kind of goes into
the into the forever um
oh my God okay so you need some
blush right there and right there oh
that doesn't seem right oh I see wait no
it needs this this brown for that cheek
and that other Brown for that cheek
nothing on the lips you need sh you need
earrings and
glasses big Hoops you got it okay big
hoop so is this like not one of you is
this just something else or and what
kind of glass oh yeah yeah oh yeah all
right you're ready for the big show get
out get out get out get out my
[Applause]
face okay
hi yeah oh you're so pretty there with
your little buttons and your stupid face
and you're following me wherever I look
that's not terrifying at all okay you
need crocodilian hair Wham you need
whatever the freck that does that
even does that even help sure let's
let's try it okay
eyebrows wait no no no sorry let's get
rid of that you don't deserve that um B
ha B ha nothing on there we need some
rocks
and Yellow on your
lips that's
disgusting oh wait oh oh wait I wasn't
done the glasses was it this glasses was
it these yeah these big nerds and
mustache wrong mustache wrong mustache
mustache no no no wrong mustache go go
get out of here go
please I got that right right okay I
don't have a lot of time to mess with
you doink so you could better you you
you you better shut up okay we got
sleepy time
gray we got fat as funky I Wham we got
glamrock blue Bam um and then big
hoop big Hoops don't understand why
you're the actual animatronics aren't
going doesn't make a lot of sense to me
but I don't ask any questions because I
don't get paid to ask questions what is
that it's some kind of neck Gator you no
it's that that for sure and then I oh my
God uh you get get out of there
pleas get get get get get get get you
come here come here what do you want
just tell me okay you're going to need a
little pink chica lips uh-oh uh no sorry
you need purple Freddy purple some Gator
I think uh you need some sleepy time I
some Gator eye big uh what do we got
what do we got what do we got bow tie
anybody got a bow tie no but mustache
you that's going there okay bow tie yep
okay we need Stars yep B and then big
stupid glasses the biggest dumbest
glasses I got get out of here please Sho
with you come here come here come here
come here no time to wait okay we got
some chica cheek we got some Freddy
chunk what I do do not have time for
that what are you what are you talking
about what do I have a timer for oh wow
we actually have someone with matching
that's just shut up hold on I my
God you okay and then beads come here
you you son shut shut up who keeps
restocking these I don't that's what I
don't know who's got headphones not
those radio headset old school Wham put
okay go get out what is shut shut up oh
my God hi hello Showtime Showtime got
some blue left got some pink chica right
well your left my right red chica brow
red Freddy uh some what was this I hope
that's that green cuz that doesn't look
quite right but we definitely no that's
not right there we go okay then we got
big
hoop Glam star mustache you have nothing
I need you have basically everything I
need never mind you only have two things
that I need get give me that okay that
goes there okay dumb mustache very dumb
hey okay I knew rockand hair then this
mustache they'll oh was please tell me
that was right okay and then what are
you missing so oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
stars get out there you star no get go
you we're right hey wo hey wo hey hey
hey wo hey wo hey wo okay all right
let's hurry up here we don't have any
time okay you're going to go there no
sorry that was there and there and then
it's you up there okay and then I don't
know if I need to wash it every time but
I sure am okay what do we got okay we
got got roxan do there the beads no tie
okay what do you have oh oh here there
we go
tie dumb mustache funky glasses yep
funky glass uh dumb
mustache okay
getable report to theck aot for your
next
shift aren't you supposed to be on
stage okay I think that went
well that went about as well as I could
have hoped and I didn't hope it would go
very
well what did I get
oh well ain't that nice are they going
to be in the room are they going to be
in the main lobby area to be perfectly
honest I don't know if that's exactly
conducive to my survival hello oh no
you're going to be over
whoopsies there you
are hi well ain't that nice ain't you
just
nice glamour prep Roxy for the main
stage in her glamrock beauty salon well
that's good okay finally we got one of
of the actual animatronics here help
Roxy get ready for performance Master
right makeup and accessories roxxy's so
nice I uh I imagine this is going to go
really
smooth
probably
hello I see only darkness before me I'm
in a void of
nothingness I can't even open a
menu
oh oh oh oh my God hi oh my God world
famous glamrock beauty
salon here we make children beautiful
presentable uhhuh and socially
acceptable uh yeah right now we have
more important things to deal with
uh-huh you need to get me ready for my
next performance
okay okay um okay what are you looking
at what I'm looking at the monitor to
get what what do you mean what are you
you looking at I'm I'm I'm oh man do I
have a wall here eyes here where do you
want my eyes what are you talking about
I am the star I what what are you oh yes
yeah you are you are you're the star
you're such a star don't worry about
anything
you stupid Fox yeah a star deserves a
star necklace which we don't seem to
have no star necklace that's strange
um hey to you ATT to me
hey how's it going you're doing so good
don't worry about a thing I need to find
a star necklace do you happen to know
where that would be because these these
are just Tres hello how are you doing
it's so good to see you this is a
peculiar game mode
hi oh man you have such eyes um hm look
at that oh wow what's over here oh
anybody seen a freaking necklace is that
oh that's not a necklace that's earrings
wait over there oh you know oh you know
that's not earrings that's that's not
earrings at all but no one here has the
right thing yeah of
course ah listen what would happen if I
didn't have what you needed or wanted or
deserved you know if there was something
that you could do as a sub itute for the
necklace that seems to be prescribed I
would appreciate uh a little insight to
that hi what are you looking at you know
something here or
there you deserve that because you're
such a freaking
star
uh-oh well that didn't go well uh I'm
going to say that straight up that that
could have been better I haven't got all
day I do um you think all this just
happens uh no you there were probably
many iterations of your design through
the ears eyes front yes I know okay
purse Oh weird okay all right uh
eyelid that's beautiful we all know it I
know it oh don't
worry I would never worry about that and
it's not here again Hey listen I'm just
going to go look around for something
real quick you are doing so good um what
are you looking at I'm looking for the
perfect something or other to make you
feel okay so it's not a necklace wait
it's not a necklace it's not a necklace
listen it's not a necklace and you're
going to have to appreciate that that's
not a necklace no matter what way it's a
nose
ring
purse all right
I know I know I know okay I want
something different all right you just
unded all the work that I did but that's
okay whatever sure hey you know you know
chica really has great style
comparatively um You probably don't
realize this but uh chica really has the
best style and the best color palette I
think we all can agree on that anyway
you would look great with big dumb
Hoops oh you know just a little
something off the why is there only one
how about eyes in your ears let me just
grab that this is not seem to be
working well you know that was close
enough anyway you only needed one
because your looks are so perfect you
don't even need two but we can't do
without this
Wham wait will you see okay the thing is
you seem to be non-receptive to the
other hoop unless this is just a left
hoop I will
Deary you you are just the sweetest as
can be
um uh see it does it just doesn't seem
like
I I didn't know the timer was running
out that low see where am I
what am I supposed to do what am I
supposed to do he doesn't want to do it
he doesn't want to let my goodness hello
okay so hey how's it going oh wow yeah
you know glamrock oh purse Wham okay and
Little Chica color come here you there
you go all right so let's figure hi
don't get sassy let's try that first
okay so that's not working it's just
working there not 100% sure about that
hey what do you think about bulls
hm not that one what do you think of
this
perfect okay so it is what did I do
wrong in the last one I changed my mind
uhhuh I want
something okay all right here
Monty okay come here come here no that
was not right okay hold on let's get rid
of that see it seems like you already
have color what are you looking at oh
stuff and things you
know oh yeah that's really working for
somebody hello looking at nothing Hey
listen how's your troubles huh dating
life bad I bet well you know hey
whatever something's going on there okay
how about some cool shades I think cool
shades are for you oh yeah anything to
block the glaring eyes looking at me and
a tiara cuz ain't you a princess Wham
wait what do you mean what what that is
correct I have that look at me I would
if I could there you go now you're ready
ta it must be I wasn't cleaning the
brush still not feeling it still not
feeling it yeah me neither I wasn't I
was thinking the exact same thing
honestly am the I know you are I know
you we all know you are we all know and
listen the star gets what the star I
don't know of course I will of course of
course of course you know if you could
just cooperate a little bit that'd be
there yeah of course oh yeah oh yeah so
hold on let me see uh this was
over where was this oh here bam okay
well that looks terrible there's that
let's see what do you want a princess
crown sure what do you want big dum
glasses sure let's see uh what do you
want no look at me oh I am oh I am am oh
I am this is going right there and then
it's uh oh big dumb glasses where big
dumb glasses none of you have looking at
nothing nothing big hoop you got that
bow tie how about a bow tie for some
reason oh God okay
yes ready for show time yeah that youve
energy think did you just take all that
stuff off smile the lips the teeth the
tip of the tongue hey I do that warm up
too hey are you removing all of that
stuff What's
um the lips in the teeth in the tip of
the tongue the lips in the teeth in the
tip of the tongue the lips in the teeth
in the tip of the tongue the lips in the
teeth in the tip of the tongue you don't
even have anything that I would put on
you great thanks thanks for making
everything irrelevant that was a really
pleasant
experience
honest
resent
hey
oh in the ancient past calling out from
Beyond time and space force Freddy
summons his Intergalactic family the
champions of fast fast Force fast Force
convene Mecha pirate Foxy the rock
chipset
chica you bionic Bonnie I would never
letay you down and and their mysterious
friends fast Force engaged combine them
all to form F Bon you won't live a happy
or successful life without them all fast
force figures each sold separately
batter is not
[Applause]
included yeah uh I guess okay well
that's kind of
fun so there was stage back there but
just not for the purpose that I was
expecting Squad Lo
ha all right whatever okay so what do I
do with
this put you there okay so now that's
virus did so I haven't done any of the
food prep I've done all of those I
haven't done oh bonka Bon a bonab bon I
want a bon a bon Bonk the bonds to get
the high score don't hit helpie
well I don't know if I'll be able to
help
it oh baby takes more hits don't let her
get you well it's just a doll what could
it
do yes I'll here are you who wants some
hm who wants some huh who's going to get
it helpie that's too okay
wonk
helpie you're going to get it every time
I don't care who you think you
are let's see here all
right that's what you get now that's
what I'm talking
[Applause]
about I did it I did it I didn't even
need to not hit helpie oh oh oh oh oh is
it because I got this wireless mic right
up here is it interrupting my connection
I don't know if it was actually helping
up there anyway right there okay we're
we're we're definitely Frozen oh my God
we're
back hey that's cool all right
oh what the
hell
oh get
down okay all
right
check that oh god there goes my
microphone well that's okay don't need
it it's a backup it's just a backup take
that
helpy I got help you think you can hide
in the Darkness truth is you cannot
helpie that's right helpie that's what
you get helpie I don't know where my
microphone went but it's out of
here take that
helpie ow God damn it helpie you're
going to get it think I might have
broken my nose this there but whatever
done that
before helpy I don't care if you don't
glow you're getting
got
take that oh yeah that's
what yeah I caught a cable there and it
just wrenched the whole headset against
my nose I'm sure you guys couldn't see
anything but a giant blur but don't
don't worry I got helpy every
time bonab Bond poister well that's nice
I'm exhausted
oh look another
thing I already have you I have this
one I I just got this one what good does
this do
me I already got that
one that's
baloney DJ music time oh boy you know oh
all right fine I'll do that listen to DJ
music man then adjust the DJ music board
to match his Beats
exactly what's going on over there you
seen that like a
glow weird watch the visualizer so it's
easier to select the right beats hit
replay if you need to hear it
again I don't know how this is going to
work is this like DDR
congratulations as part of your
Superstar party package you are entitled
to private DJ lessons with the music man
everyone wants to be a DJ and you are no
different well I'm not an example will
play use the controls in front of you to
match that example if you are unsure of
your music Loop refer to the visualizer
on the console uh-huh do not displease
the DJ it does not react well to
disappointment this Behavior bug has
been reported and is under
investigation lesson number one begins
now okay do I have a choice can I leave
I react to disappointment well
either yeah oh God no no no no no oh my
God oh my God oh my God hi hello oh
yeah only got eyes for
rockan and money I see who what in the
Hologram uh-huh oh yeah yeah was that
it
what I'm sorry did you was was I
supposed to was was I supposed to do do
[Music]
that
isn't that
it ah blue Checkers and then electricity
symbols I
think okay so each of these I wish I had
who hi oh boy oh oh oh
oh ah thank
[Music]
you I think so
right oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
hi yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay all
right
okay hey that's it's all right uh-huh so
look can I hear it again thank you uh
lightning
bolts I'm just trying to hear what they
are that's it you can't say it's not
that because it's it certainly
is uh-huh
[Music]
yeah
yeah that was it
right
yeah
hi
what oh God okay all right I
thought you're giv me a lot of tries I
[Music]
guess
no is that it was that not
it
yeah oh that oh ah yeah
okay
oh
uhuh
uhoh oh what what it has been determined
that you have sufficient musical Talent
you May proceed to lesson two on your
next visit additional charges May
apply
uh-huh good
um good I can't hear the difference on
that last one but maybe I'm just
stupid DJ where is he going to fit how
how is he going to fit I don't
understand how he's going to
fit oh god oh not every time
Bora
[Music]
oh that makes more sense that makes a
lot more sense well that's lovely um
great good oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh did I miss an opportunity to
get another one because I didn't put
that there well I probably did but it's
all the time I got four for this episode
so I'm end that there with Mr Music Man
beaming down at me and thank you
everybody so much for watching hope you
had a good day happy holidays Merry
Christmas Happy New Year it's coming up
and more Five Nights at Freddy's coming
up very soon thank you and as always I
will see
you in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye he